it took the combined efforts of villages
and more than 80 hours of waiting to
take the boat out of the water right
over there is a boat that capsized just
a few days ago with more than 300 people
on boat and it was meant to carry a few
dozens but unfortunately hundreds were
on it and sadly our lives were lost
there was widespread expectations that
there could be some bodies in the water
in the boat so that when the bodies are
retrieved they could be given a proper
burial unfortunately none was found now
the mood here is that of frustration
that of sadness that of grief on
Wednesday we stayed in a family house
where nine members of the family one
lost in that accident close to them
there was another family that lost 18
people in that boat accident and we also
met a woman a mother who survived the
boat capsize three of our children
drowned including one that is supposed
to get married in one month's time it's
clear on the faces of people that it
could take a very long time for members
of these communities affected by this
tragedy to recover enable Community for
example more than 10 percent of that
Community has been wiped off by this
tragic incident that happened on Monday